partout les mêmes temple de la
consommation
ici à destrelland blanc web ou là au
centre commercial duparc à la réunion
avec la même petite musique
ici on trouve tout et même plus que ça
mais derrière le vernis de la grande
distribution
il y a une double réalité la position
oligarchique de certains et
parallèlement la sous représentation de
la production locale
après la filière pêche à mayotte
c'est le nouveau cheval de bataille de
fer et d'hommes - avez-vous là les
locaux de l'association verviers la
boîte à idées de mac du bois et de ses
équipes
il passe les outre-mer au scanner de la
lutte contre le chômage de masse et la
cherté de la vie
ça c'est pas les hommes qui préconise
c'est sol et vous du président de
république quand il est en voyage
officiel la réunion donc il préconise la
fin des monopoles ou des oligopoles et
je pense que c'est absolument nécessaire
parce que clairement aujourd'hui les
situations de monopole ou de lego paul
étouffent l'économie des territoires
d'outre-mer on a trop attendu
aujourd'hui vous voyez les gens montrent
des mécontentements très très fort donc
maintenant il faut des résultats il faut
obtenir maintenant des changements très
profonds dans les habitudes des
opérateurs économiques notamment de la
grande distribution il faut qu'ils
changent
vous parlez de pôles d'attractivité
qu'il faut d'une certaine manière au prg
dans des habitudes qui sont prises et en
tant que propriétaire ceux qui possèdent
ces pôles d'attractivité vont vous dire
mais mais de quoi je me mêle
oui mais justement je vais vous dire de
quoi je me mêle de quoi parlons nous on
parle de centres commerciaux qu'est-ce
que ça casse en commercial c'est un
magasin amiral grands magasins qui dans
lequel on peut acheter en général toute
la partie alimentaire et agroalimentaire
puis d'autres d'autres raisons que l'on
ne connaît bien et puis à côté de ce
magasin amiral il ya des petits magasins
va plus petit
qui va être un magasin bricolage un
autre qui va être un magasin pour aller
vendre de la brioche à un autre expert
bon tous ses magasins là ils font partie
de ce que moi j'appelle un groupement
d'intérêt économique informelle c'est à
dire qu'en gros tous les gens qui
dirigent à semana dans certains cas
c'est le même dans d'autres cas sont
d'autres opérateurs mais globalement
tous ces gens là ils sont main dans la
main donc ça ça constitue là un
groupement d'intérêt économique
informelle dans lequel vous ne pouvez
pas rentrer parce que là la porte est
fermée ils ont péri mais très et dans
l'autre sens quand vous regardez par
exemple dans l'agroalimentaire
l'agroalimentaire aujourd'hui les
filières agroalimentaires
ce sont souvent ces mêmes enseignes
qu'on a trouvé en eau qu'on va appeler
le front-office 1 ce qui est devant
d'accord ce sont les mêmes que organisé
en ligne dans le ver ticket dans la
verticalité les filières économiques
c'est à dire que là à ce niveau là vous
avez des gens qui ont fait par exemple
des importations puis de l'art
transformation et puis ensuite de la
mise dans les rayons et ces gens là en
vertical il constitue également un
groupement d'intérêt économique
concernant les mais la chaîne donc ils
ont la verticalité dans toute la partie
la fabrication et ils ont
l'horizontalité dans la partie vente
mais ils sont pas illégaux pouvaient
être c'est pas une question d'inégalité
on n'est pas dans la légalité ou
l'illégalité on est en train d'expliquer
qu'on est dans un système qui verrouille
intégralement au profit de quelques-uns
toute l'économie des territoires
et qu'est ce qu'un père président des
opérateurs
monsieur x ou y gulf faire la même chose
en tout cas de faire un peu d'un triste
mais vous pouvez pas parce que le ticket
d'accès aujourd'hui trop élevée
aujourd'hui vous imaginez qu'un centre
commercial c'est une immense machine un
centre commercial il faut se rendre
compte qu est-ce que c'est ça fait
parfois jusqu'à 100 millions d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires un magasin dans le
magasin amiral donc aller aujourd'hui
faire concurrence c'est impossible vous
avez des emprises qui ont été faites
immobilière vous avez un tout un réseau
qui a été construit et croyez moi les
gens qui détiennent aujourd'hui ces
centres commerciaux sont pas prêts de
lâcher on a un grand combat à mener
alors c'est d'abord un combat de
conviction - avoir je m'adresse aux as
et grand propriétaire de centres
commerciaux jours d'écouté
franchement les yeux dans les yeux votre
affaire ça ne peut pas durer
vous pouvez plus continuer aujourd'hui à
étouffer l'économie au seul profit de
quelques-uns
ça c'est pas possible parce que ça veut
dire cherté de la vie mais vous savez
quand on est en situation de monopole
les prix ils sont plus faciles à faire
que quand on est en concurrence
et moi je dis que qu'est ce que c'est
qu'une situation de monopole ils se sont
donnés un centre commercial c'est à lui
tout seul un monopole et quand on
m'explique que les clients peuvent aller
ailleurs mais c'est pas vrai quand vous
avez des gens qui sont à quelques
kilomètres d'un centre commercial c'est
là qu'ils vont ils vont pas surtout dans
les territoires d'outre-mer où vous
savez comme moi à quel point il est
difficile de se déplacer parce que les
routes sont tout le temps encombrer les
gens vont pas passer des heures et des
heures pour aller chercher quelque chose
un peu moins cher donc les gens sont
donc contraints d'aller dans ces centres
commerciaux il n'y a pas de choix
ils sont obligés d'y aller et en bout de
ligne cette contrainte est utilisé par
les propriétaires commerciaux pour
bloquer intégralement leur profil et
canal j voi vous imaginez bien que les
gens que vous ciblez ne vont pas
accepter de partager leur pouvoir alors
d'une certaine manière ça leur
appartient et goom
en plus du fait qu'ils sont
propriétaires on est sur deux périmètres
différents vous évoquez la loi d'abord
les lois sont vivantes donc la loi de la
réglementation doivent évoluer donc
changé donc moi j'en appelle déjà à
changer un peu cette loi dans le
logement social
il était impossible de peu de dire qu'il
fallait de logements sociaux dans les
villes qui étaient riches où on voulait
pas les gens qui étaient moins riches
voilà bon à la loi est passée par là
puis maintenant on est obligé
d'aucuns me disent oui mais c'est pas
respecté non peut-être mais en tout cas
ils payent la note
donc on voit bien là qu'il ya une vraie
possibilité de la loi à intervenir et il
faut intervenir d'urgence parce que la
situation dans laquelle on se trouve
aujourd'hui c'est une situation du monde
d'avant le monde ne peut plus tourner
comme ça le monde c'est une affaire de
partage est aujourd'hui la modernité
celle partage moi j'incite vraiment les
grands opérateurs
ces propriétaires qui aujourd'hui sont
ceux qui tiennent l'économie
je les incite vraiment aujourd'hui avoir
la question sous un autre angle que
simplement j'ai le droit mais aussi de
quelle est ma plainte ma part de
responsabilité quelle est ma part
d'humanisme dans le développement
économique de nos territoires
moi c'est là où je vais chercher les
gens en leur disant peut-être que vous
avez des droits qui sont des droits
marquée par la loi mais vous avez aussi
des devoirs qui sont marqués par
l'humanisme aulas vous abordez quand
même
[Musique]
un domaine qui participe du sentiment
j'en veux dire le partage
alors quel est le modus operandi que
préconise air et d'hommes moi ce que je
dis aujourd'hui jeudi qu' il ya
aujourd'hui des endroits qui sont des
véritables centres d'attraction
commercial pourquoi parce que c'est son
copain sûr on me qu'on la dit toutes les
enseignes ont les parkings les petites
cantines éventuellement pour que les
enfants ont pu s'amuser enfin avec les
petites aires de jeux etc tout ça c'est
fait mais ça ça c'est fait quoi aller ça
c'est fait que le pognon public c'est à
dire écoutez ces centres commerciaux eux
les centres commerciaux qui sont nés sur
la sur rémunération la sur-rémunération
bénéficie en premier lieu sequana sur
heavy nuage savez comme moi que la
surrémunération c'est une rémunération
supérieure de 40 % dans certains
territoires plus de 50 dans d'autres
territoires qui sont cette
surrémunération c'est une
surrémunération qui permet notamment au
départ un tous les gentils viennent de
l'administration de pouvoir faire face à
nos obligations sur un territoire dont
ils sont tous le problème c'est que
évidemment tout est monté avec la vague
mais les gens qui n'ont pas la
surrémunération eux qui sont contraints
avec des écarts de salaire par rapport à
un prix qui est toujours affichée
supérieur je vais pas vous redire ici
tout le monde tous les gens qui nous
écoutent savent les écarts de prix a une
histoire de poulet n'ya pas longtemps on
a vu un poulet à 50 euros mais vous
savez il faut pas aller chercher le
poulet 50 euros il faut aller chercher
le prix des no il faut aller chercher le
prix du riz faut aller chercher des
choses simples et puis les fruits et
légumes notamment bon ça c'est plus
acceptable moi ce que je dis aujourd'hui
il faut il faut comprendre comment c'est
venu donc jeudi l'argent public qui a
permis etc la sur-rémunération de créer
ces centres d'attraction commercial et
puis les infrastructures quand
aujourd'hui vous allez dans un centre
commercial
il ya des routes pour y aller il ya
d'éclairage public il ya éventuellement
les forces de police les jours de les
jours de grande affluence qui sont sur
les ronds-points et c'est alors on va
objecter que les propres et à 200
commerciaux payent des impôts
enfin ils payent pas d'impôts à due
concurrence des infrastructures
routières qui sont mises à disposition
le deuxième point est un point très
important c'est que c'est ces filières
dont je vais parler tout à l'heure qui
sont les filières des gens qui
produisent localement et par exemple
l'histoire des yaourts
vous avez des gens qui produisent des
yachts et qui sont un peu dans ce
conglomérat ce que j'appelle les
groupements d'intérêt économique
informelle que sont des entreprises très
proches de ceux qui ont les centres
commerciaux leur valeur et la face oui
en ce qui concerne par exemple les
antilles vous parlez des békés oui oui
bien sûr mais vous savez je parle je
partais le caire quand je pars délégués
soit on perd les becquets qui sont eux
aux manettes parce que a indiqué qu'ils
ne vont pas l imperméable aux paillotes
fait partie mais le groupe hayotte un
groupe mais moi je veux pas rentrer dans
la stigmatisation oui oui on peut en
parler mais je veux pas stigmatiser
je veux pas tomber là dedans parce que
c'est un problème qui est bien au delà
du groupe hayotte donc
et quand on a un groupe quels qu'ils
soient qui tient une filière cette
filière dont économique par exemple en
parler des yaourts bon celui qui
fabrique les yaourts les fabriquent avec
quoi avec ce qu'on appelle les fonds de
compensation possible
c'est assez de l'argent public qui est
de l'argent européen attention qu'est ce
que c'est que l'argent européen c'est de
l'argent français qui est parti en
europe
et cet argent est redistribuée sous
certaines conditions que c'est la
réunion c'est l'argent c'est notre
argent c'est l'argent des contribuables
donc ça ça permet de récupérer les
écarts qu'il y a entre la capacité de
fabriquer largement comme en métropole
ou fabriques qui ont plus petites
quantités qui coûte plus cher
là ya de l'argent qui tombe c'est en
dizaines de millions d'euros
surtout à nous parler et puis quand ces
entreprises là ont besoin d'acheter des
machines pour pouvoir fabriquer leurs
yaourts ou leur crème glacée ou où
mettre le jus le jus de fruits - jerry
bon tous ces gens là bénéficient de la
défiscalisation
donc on voit bien quand on additionne le
vertical on a de la défiscalisation et
on a des fonds des fonds structurels
européens et le fonds possède notamment
est contournée en haut on à la sur
rémunération et on a les infrastructures
imaginez quand même que tout ça c'est
nos impôts dont moi je dis aujourd'hui
que l'attractivité commerciale qui a été
créé elle a été créée avec cet argent
public en partie dont on parle de ces
zones on parle de ses autres et moi je
dis que ces zones là elles doivent
donner un accès libre un accès libre
c'est à dire sans droits de ce qu'on
appelait autrefois un droit de cuissage
pour pour dire ça
ao gens qui vont vendre là il faut
donner quoi il faut donner l'accès à la
filière agroalimentaire moi je voudrais
qu on est en permanence sur le parking
sur le parking là où les gens viennent
pas à des dizaines de kilomètres qu'on
puisse étaler tous les jours un marché
avec des producteurs locaux qui ont
droit de qui ont le droit d'être dans le
flux de la clientèle qui est amenée ici
car cette clientèle je le redis
n'appartient pas aujourd'hui moralement
elle n'appartient pas à ce qu'ils ont
capté parce que nous avons payé cher
nous avec nos impôts nous en paye très
cher pour qu'il puisse faire ça donc
pour nous résumer vous demandez à ces
monopoles de permettre à monsieur
tartempion qui est producteur de
s'installer dans leur reprise dans une
certaine proportion je présume que ça
gratuitement
il faut que ce soit organisée peut venir
évidemment ici les producteurs locaux ou
éventuellement les coopératives qui
unissent les plaies les locaux
il faut que ce soit vraiment locale il
faut que ce soit fait à garantie de
qualité des produits parce que dans
certains territoires on connaît bien les
problèmes qu'on a encore une fois un des
groupes des groupes qui ont souillé
lourdement et pour très longtemps
la terre donc il faut expliquer aussi
que les ses producteurs locaux vont
pouvoir sortir des produits de très
grande qualité pour que le consommateur
soit un consommateur content et
sécuriser tous à 7 à mettre en place il
ya des règles minimales par contre ce
que moi je ne veux pas c'est que les
propriétaires des centres commerciaux
fasse payer un droit d'accès pour payer
le le flux quand je conseille internes
existent il ya aujourd'hui à danser des
emprises la rue des petits îlots fait ça
mais à quel prix sage ou non cela donc
aujourd'hui c'est ça le fond du problème
c'est que si vous devez payer un espace
pour vendre des carottes ou des patates
douces au prix auquel mont blanc est opé
obligé de payer son espace au bon marché
dont le bon 7e arrondissement parisien
ça n'a pas de sens aujourd'hui ce qu'il
faut c'est favoriser la production
locale pour plusieurs raisons il y en a
au moins trois la première raison c'est
que la production locale c'est de
l'emploi local c'est là dessus qu'il est
un homme se bat nous nous sommes là pour
ça donc si on produit localement on va
créer de l'emploi le deuxième réseau et
attendez on me dit souvent oui mais les
producteurs ils sont pas fiables et
c'est ta ta ta ta ta les producteurs des
territoires sont extrêmement fiable tout
problème c'est qu'ils n'ont pas marché
et s'ils ont un marché constant ils
seront produire de manière constante
seulement quand vous avez un archi en
dents-de-scie et en quantités produites
et ont pris vous pouvez effectivement
mal base et une économie de
développement donc je dis aujourd'hui
que tous les gens que je connais dans
les territoires et vous savez que je
connais beaucoup de monde parce que j'y
vais beaucoup tous ces gens là sont des
gens qui sont des producteurs notamment
les jeunes et qui sont tout à fait
capables de produire convenablement
ça c'est numéro un ensuite numéro deux
il faut arrêter de faire venir des
salades par avion écoutez l'empreinte
carbone du matin au soir on est en train
d'expliquer ça bon maintenant il faut
produire localement parce que c'est dans
le sens de l'histoire de l'histoire de
l'humanité
localement avec la possibilité d'écouler
la fin j'ai évidemment tout le problème
est là c'est que si vous n'avez pas
accès au marché en bout de ligne
ben vous pouvez rien produire et enfin
troisièmement c'est une condition de
prix vous pouvez pas aujourd'hui de dire
à quelqu'un vient vendre si vous le
piqué toute sa marge
si la marge et ratatiner et épique et
complètement parlait pas par les
opérateurs qui ont un les la puissance
de vente
ces gens là ne dirons rien gagné alors
voilà ces trois conditions maximales
look
le noeud gordien de l'histoire
intervient dire voilà doux rêveur parce
que ça pour l'accepter il faut qu'il y
ait quand même une des avenues des
dispositions légales
écoutez moi ce que je pense c'est qu'il
faut il faut parler avec les gens je
suis pas sûr que ce que je raconte là ce
que je dis comme histoire du futur c'est
à dire cette capacité de permettre aux
filières agro alimentaires fruits et
légumes la filière
les relais et puis la filière viande je
suis pas certain que certains
propriétaires de grands supermarchés
soit pas aller coûte de ça et se disent
finalement c'est vrai on a sept
responsables sociaux talent de permettre
à des à des producteurs locaux de venir
s'installer sur nos parkings et devant
que certains produits oui du coup nous
vendront moins de ces produits là dans
nos étals mais ils ont tellement
tellement de référence 1
est-ce que la responsabilité sociétale
est soluble dans une certaine
responsabilité historique
on connaît ce qui fonde les sociétés
ultramarines
vous remettez en question là quelque
chose qui participe de la structure
chavire politique même de ces contrées
là non mais je remets en question quoi
je remets en question l'ancien monde
moi j'avance comme enfin comme un
économiste
quelqu'un qui regarde et pilotant un
observateur attentif vous savez il est
bien placé pour savoir que je suis
impliqué dans les territoires de thomert
depuis plus de trente ans donc je vois
évoluer les sociétés et aujourd'hui je
dis aujourd'hui que la possibilité est
offerte historiquement de changer de
changer de braquet
c'est à dire d'aller vers une société
plus fraternelle
ça c'est clair il ya un meneur et est
donc plus responsable parce que quand on
parle de plus fraternelle suis pas doux
rêveur c'est que vous savez quand il
n'ya pas de fraternité les gens
s'opposent et moi je veux éviter ça
[Musique]